die Erzherzog johann-kaserne in Strass
hat vergangenes Wochenende allen Grund
zu feiern 170 Jahre garnisons statt Tag
der offenen Tür und ein Festakt
anlässlich 70 Jahre eh schon der Marie
der erste Akku 1952 gilt als
Gründungstag der b-jonie jener
sonderformation der schon am Ring die
schließlich 1955 dort Keimzelle unseres
Bundesheeres wurde
die Aufgaben der beige war nicht nur der
Grenzschutz und die Bekämpfung von
Unruhen sondern auch der Einsatz bei
Naturkatastrophen sowie taktische
Einsätze im Alarmfall womit der
eigentliche Kampfeinsatz gemeint war die
Idee schon der Marie wird im August 1952
als sonderformation in sechs sogenannten
Gendarmerie Schulen mit rund 5000 Mann
gegründet das Ziel der Westalliierten
Besatzer war die Aufstellung einer
soforteinsetzbaren Truppe die dann
schließlich mit der Unterzeichnung des
Staatsvertrages 1955 zu Keimzellen des
neuen Bundesheeres geworden ist für die
Bezeichnung gibt es keine verlässliche
Erklärung war es die B Bereitschaft die
B bewaffnete oder die B besondere oder
einfach die B Gendarmerie im Gegensatz
zur A der allgemeinen anscheindarmerie
wir können diese Frage leider nicht
beantworten in seinem Festansprache gibt
general in Ruhe Karl Meitzen Einblicke
als Flugzeuge des ersten Kurses der
b-jon der Marie in Straß 1952 ein das
geht nicht gehört den nicht zu den
damals gebräuchigen flossen im
Dienstbetrieb bzw Auftrag der Füllung
das hat es nicht gegeben das war meins
also in einem Schlafraum haben nur 30
Grad für dann aber 35
das geht nicht aus Zahnbrücken Tapeten
35 Minuten Plattform das meine ich damit
also so etwas
weiter alles darauf ausgerichtet
Aufträge zu erfüllen rasch möglich so
wie es in unserer angelogen drinnen
steht die Befehle deiner Vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen an
dieser Stelle sei auch am beispielstrass
ein Dank und das ist mein
Herzensanliegen an jene Offiziere zu
wiederholen die sich nach ihrem
Kriegseinsatz zum Teil nach langer
Gefangenschaft der Aufgabe stellten auf
Aufbau des Bundesheeres mitzuwirken der
definierte Generalstabschef Rudolf
Striedinger bedankt sich bei den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten für ihren
Einsatz und erinnert mit dem Zitat nur
wer die Geschichte kennt kann auch die
Zukunft gestalten an die Verpflichtung
zu Bewahrung der Traditionspflege im
Bundesheer ich möchte schließen damit
dass das österreichische Bundesheer als
Tradition mit durchaus Respekt und
Ehrfurcht auf die Leistungen der
beschanamerie zurückblickt weil wer
nicht in der Lage ist seine Geschichte
zu verstehen der wird auch nicht in der
Lage sein seine Zukunft in die richtige
Richtung zu entwickeln daher mein Dank
an das jägerparteium 17 nochmals dass
wir hier die Verbindung zwischen
Vergangenheit Gegenwart und auch Zukunft
so in dieser festlichen Art und Weise
gestalten können es lebe dass
jägerpatron 17 aus der Tradition der
österreichischen beige horrido bei der
Leistungsschau informieren sich
zahlreiche Gäste von den
möglichen
[Musik]